foreign
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for having me sure what's
up
so about three weeks ago I went to one
of those required retirement meetings
for work and they referred me to a debt
counselor due to my debt and the debt
counselor recommended bankruptcy so I
went home and spoke with my husband we
bought your book The Total Money
Makeover right in two days we're fully
committed we have about 1500 already in
an emergency fund so we're trying to
move on to baby step two is it debt
snowball we stopped using all our credit
cards we listed all our debts in order
and we're trying to make a budget the
budget is really hard because I have
five kids and it seems like emergencies
are constantly happening last month we
spent over three thousand dollars in car
repairs and just yesterday we had like a
surprise 50 saxophone fee for my son
there's just so many unexpected fees and
costs for seven people bumping around in
the world prior to This Money Makeover
we live really simply we only went out
to dinner like once a semester for good
report cards our only vacation this year
was a 40 camping trip in the tent so you
know we're selling everything we're
selling so much actually the kids think
they're next but I'm worried that we're
still going to end up with too much
months and not enough money and that we
won't even be able to get to the debt
snowball
how much debt do you have
I have
um
let's see 2034
37.47 with the car and not including my
mortgage and how much of that is the car
10. okay and what's the other 37
um
card debt except for
three thousand in one last kid in braces
okay all right so 37 30 33 000 in credit
card debt and um so you've been covering
all of this chaos and disorganization
and shortages with credit cards in the
past that's where 33 000 came from am I
right
yes okay
so you made a good decision because
bankruptcy really won't help you
you'll be right back here 10 months
later if you don't fix this on the core
what's your household income
150 thousand between the two of us
before taxes
okay you're all right what's your house
payment
920 a month oh you're definitely all
right okay you're gonna make it all
right here here's what first happens
okay these to start with saxophone
payments aren't a surprise
that's a known quantity that everyone
knew was coming
just no one is organized in this house
enough to bother to tell everybody
what's going on
okay but I mean that that's not they
don't suddenly say this is going to
happen uh so there's two opportunities
but we've got to one of the things we
had to do our kids our three kids was to
train them to not bring us any surprises
they've got to tell us about everything
early and often so we can get it into
the budget or they're going to not get
to do it
that's what ends up happening and about
the time they miss out on one thing
because they they forgot to tell us that
little Georgie has a birthday party well
you don't go because we don't have it in
the budget to buy a little Georgie a
gift and you're not going over there
looking like a freeloader so your little
butt's staying at home next time you'll
tell us about the time I did that twice
all of a sudden they became experts on
planning at eight years old
yeah and so what's happening is you guys
you know you have a chaotic life because
you have a big family everybody working
everybody's running different directions
and the chaos is showing up in the
disorganization of the handling of the
money and it's costing you all of your
peace and a lot of your money
because you can't you can't because your
budget Jayden I both did it in her head
while you were telling us you're you're
completely able to make these this work
yeah the good news is you know up until
this point you were just flying by the
seat of your pants but now you've read
the book and you're like okay we've got
to get on a budget and now you're going
to start to implement that and you will
find you know it's going to take a
couple of months to iron that out and
get it really where it's you know you're
not going over it or busting in certain
areas that where you're really
understanding okay this is what we spend
this is what we can spend and in your
situation there's you got five kids
there's gonna be a lot of line items on
there and it's something that because of
the size of your family this idea of set
it and forget it is not it shouldn't
work for anybody but it's certainly not
going to work for you you're gonna have
a new budget every month and it's going
to include this month a saxophone
payment next month does not
um hopefully uh and um uh you know this
month has a field trip
next month does not and and you're also
going to have some miscellaneous
category for just miscellaneous kid
things that come up you're all because
it's predictable that one of them is
going to the pediatrician at least every
60 days
with five of them okay that's fairly
predictable whether it's uh the flu or
stitches I don't know but one of them is
going to go get a Doc Bill
am I wrong
no you're right how old are they
um they are 11 13 16 my 18 year old just
graduated high school my 21 year old has
autism so he's going to be with us a lot
longer so it's not as much as not as
much pediatrician as it is they eat a
lot football game basketball game all
that stuff yeah you got a house full of
teenagers so they eat everything in
sight and the and they're you know the
hormones are pumping so there's a lot of
drama and there's a lot of stuff going
on I mean and if you let all of that
infect your budget instead of you guys
controlling see the trick with budgeting
is you'd flip it and and it's hard it's
very difficult for the first three
months but you flip it and you say I'm
going to make the money behave I'm not a
victim to a lack of money I'm going to
tell this money what to do and by doing
that I'm going to make some choices I
don't think you've been overspending I
don't think you're out of control I
don't think you're buying a bunch of
crap you can't afford you didn't call me
up with a 57 000 car payment you call me
with a ten thousand dollar car payment
and you make a hundred and fifty but I
do think you've got autism and teenagers
and you got a bunch of them and so
you're just in the middle of chaos and
disorganization and that's eating your
lunch literally it's eating your money
yeah and so you have got to get up above
it and make all this crap calm down line
up and behave and that includes some of
the behaviors with the kids but most of
all it includes uh you guys saying okay
this is where every dollar is going
because if you start at the top with
your household income and you stop your
401k and you're not getting a tax refund
because you're not having too much
withheld and you don't have anything
coming out of your check except taxes
and you sit there and you go okay I got
a hundred fifty thousand bucks I got a
900 house payment I got a car payment I
got food that is equal to this and
there's no restaurants in that because
I'm getting out of debt and I've got uh
and you lay this out you can do this you
can do this Mia there's room in this
it's possible it doesn't you don't feel
powerful right now but you've taken the
first big steps away from the Cliff of
falling off into bankruptcy and you're
just three steps back inside we'll help
you okay but first thing I want to do is
encourage you and tell you there is
enough money here to make this work and
it's going to be hard but you can do it
you've got the stuff but it is a matter
of taming the chaos tiger